Captain America the Winter Soldier is
directed by the Russo brothers and stars
Chris Evans is Captain America Scarlett
Johansson is Black Widow Nick Fury as
Nick Fury
Samuel Jackson is Nick Fury come on
anthony mackie is Falcon and I'm not
going to say who plays the Winter
Soldier just in case you are one of the
few people who don't know who plays a
Winter Soldier in this movie you get to
see shield as an organization kind of
turn on itself certain things happen
that caused people to be revealed for
who they really are and Captain America
has suddenly hunted by this organization
that he thought was awesome but not so
much I'm not gonna spoil much by this
movie the essential plot is that the
Winter Soldier is an incredibly precise
assassin who is sent to take out Captain
America and they have to figure out
where he's from who he is what's his
past is there a way to defeat him also
this whole shield thing is going on it's
looming over them and this movie is
freaking amazingly great this is
hands-down the best
standalone Marvel film we have had so
far the only competition that really had
was that first Iron Man movie in my mind
and this film exceeds it on every level
in regards to sequels this is one of the
best sequels we've had in many years
this reminds me of the Empire Strikes
Back or reminds me of The Dark Knight it
just blows everything about the original
away one of the best parts about this
movie is how political it is and use its
cone for me that's something I have no
interest in politic but this movie is
very realistic and grounded it's by far
Marvel's most grounded film it feels
like a real world where you're able to
accept all these things that happen but
it's still very funny and it has that
great field that the Avengers had where
characters have all these little in
jokes and you can tell certain things
are pulled right out of the comics for
fans to be very happy about lots of
little Easter eggs in there a lot of
people will be very satisfied with many
things in this movie if you can pay
attention but the actual plot is so
suspenseful and actually tension-filled
and really riveting it wasn't just the
action scenes that were very well done
and extremely exciting the dialogue
scenes were just as interesting and that
is a humongously awesome thing to
see in a movie like this to see these
characters taken seriously and that's
one of the things that fans are
extremely excited about to see these
people be like yeah these comic-book
characters you grew up with they're
pretty awesome and we're going to sell
them as actual people and we're going to
show a real organization it's going to
feel realistic and it's going to be
amazing so because of the fact that the
characters are set up so well the
relationships are set up so well the
political aspect of the film feels so
thrilling and almost like a basically a
spy movie really because of that all the
awesome action sequences are just
heightened and everything about them
work even better the direction is very
very good it looks really awesome and
realistic I know the Russo brothers
tried to use very minimal CGI
there's definitely CGI in the movie but
a lot of the stunt work feels extremely
hardcore and that's something that I
really talked about this movie there's a
little bit of shaky cam throughout the
movie but it wasn't poorly done shaky
cam and you could tell that the actors
were doing amazing stunts it wasn't like
they were trying to hide things it was
used to boost it and I think they did a
good job that even though it could have
been a little less close up at points
Chris Evans is fantastic as Captain
America once again Scarlett Johansson is
awesome and sexy as Black Widow this is
a really great showcase also for Samuel
Jackson as Nick Fury he gets a lot of
work in this movie he's got a lot of
stuff to do and his character gets a lot
of great moments the Winter Soldier in
the film is amazing he is such a cool
villain he has very minimal dialogue at
first they set him up so well with the
way that directed his scenes very
ominous and completely badass he was an
awesome villain also one of my favorite
characters in this movie was Anthony
Mackie as Falcon he added a great sense
of comic relief to the film but he was
also just really Stern and heartfelt and
you really believed his characters
appreciation for all was going on I
thought he was just great in the movie
Robert Redford was awesome too and it
was cool to see him in this political
esque thriller because he's done great
stuff like that with all the President's
Men in the past and he was very dark in
this role and he really went places and
you really bought into his performance
he did such a great job Captain America
the Winter Soldier is my favorite
standalone Marvel film we've had so far
it doesn't quite exceed the Avengers but
the Avengers has Hulk and Thor and Iron
Man and all those people in the same
movie so it's not even fair but this
movie is really really a
exciting it's a film that feels
realistic and grounded with awesome
action sequences and fantastic dialogue
and characters that you can actually
latch on to and care about I have but
one gripe of the film and it's this
scene that involved this computer
consciousness that just felt like it
detracted and suddenly went in a
different direction from the feel of the
whole movie but it was a very brief
scene and so it's not really like a huge
problem it was just like it's two-minute
period where I was like this this feels
weird
all-in-all I adore this movie and I
cannot wait to see it again I'm gonna
give Captain America the Winter Soldier
and a definitely check this one out it
is one of the best Marvel films we've
had so far the second best in my opinion
so guys if you have seen the movie
because you probably have because for
some reason America seems to have gotten
Captain America last out of the world
for whatever reason let me know what you
think of it when you see it or if you
have already seen it let me know as well
also this is pretty cool
Jake Baldino from because video games
and pretty much it and I did this really
awesome skit for Metal Gear Solid on his
channel I really hope you go check that
out because Jake did such a great job
with that video he did a really awesome
job editing that and it's a lot of fun
to see him and I dressed up the snake we
have a codec conversation and everything
I really hope you guys go check that out
I let the link for that in the
description below thank you so much for
watching guys and as always if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck man highs
you